which is when you start again do an
introduction now I'm just going to start
altering the box ok grabbing it I got
concerned
hello reject nation
Greg Alva here jeddak away.i Tarka a
charter Kirk and Jabby Kawai from the
jab eco a channel here today to help me
get nerdy cated here
that's a nerd and educated combined I've
been a while since I've done one of
these but it's an unboxing video of none
other than why I tend to wear a lot of
shirts from them I'm supposed to be
unboxing these and I kind of forget and
I just sort of collect all the items
don't actually do a video on but I got
an email like oh yeah I'm supposed to be
done ammaji Susan Hutchins free bike the
sale to them quite the salesman here and
that mean IROC their shirts this might
be one of their shirts actually Achara
what I'm going to need you to do I need
you to reach in this box there's a
little pamphlet that says the month and
the theme of what's ever in this box
today right so I'll you find that first
I don't want you to show me a picture
it's not probably many items in there
how much Brian that's not before you can
anything I guess I'm going to go Greg
okay I thought this would be a great
time to do it so this is the other items
that limited the dead he got this in
Japan when he was like I remember today
this was like part of the kitchen it is
a mod of test these inner tubes glass oh
thank god more items that I could really
use in my life right now put mine space
for them okay my brother doesn't want to
hold on to me no no I have a bunch of
his stuff I just thought that you should
have some of it also what's this it's
some very collected random things that
was one of them I had them separately in
my display case and I was like oh
Richard have some of this because he
doesn't have anything related to death
oh well thank you yeah Jackie show it
that was very well time I haven't any a
minute to find them that pamphlet okay
are you ready what's today is month s
genius yeah alright alright a Chara
start unveiling the items one at a time
please you're the Price is Right model
host for us are you ready I'm ready
don't start the big ones
so it's hiding she's gonna know what
they are too man
oh sweet lightning man that's right
jabbing here so you can tell me what
this stuff is I know that I'm a big fan
of the flash TV show I don't read the
comics but this is cool I got to learn
how to so you know so yeah every agent
on Windows it is so every asian woman no
sudden yeah my auntie when the
seamstress I used to not like this at
all
yeah are you searching for that sadly I
don't reckon it's ours
really yes Oh guitar or rectangular
shaped objects well I want to put this
on a pair of jeans I can write on my
crotch if you have a fresh batch I'm an
Asian woman ASAP and she will stitch it
to your chest for you yeah well I mean
guys this is pretty foolproof
it looks like it's an iron-on patch oh
it's an iron-on yeah that's what you
mean I could just iron it on yeah not
like Iron Man my on it Gregory just
needs to fight an iron oh it's true an
iron board and then I'm halfway there
people well you could just use your leg
and iron throughout it odd just shoot me
he knows that's how you do it like a man
ready next item the char up okay another
smaller item are you ready to the pin ah
no was that or is that from Oh coming
from Batman oh that's so cool
this is the word that I go off when javi
would beat me up when I was younger
can you add that in later Wow haha I in
iMovie I have no idea how to do that
I'm grandma grandpa PNG of it and drop
it on top of it should work but they're
stickers they're magnets what - there
you go this could be hurting someone
noises or sex noises whichever one you
want them to be I would like them to be
Church noises yeah Bank separator how
our Father
oh cool that's cool these are genius
items they're very very cool
are you ready for the next one I'm
prepared okay sure oh my god I was wait
can I have this Wimbley oh this is all
notice but one thing I always use from
these guys I was too big for you no then
what is something cool shirt that's a
cool shirt I want that one oh oh oh
that's an awesome sure it's too big for
you giving me nothing in the last three
years
I want the shirts here you go here's
your flat patches that is so cool would
have been like Batman V Superman he like
killed Superman and formed some hybrid
with him that looks like that's what it
is yeah that's way too big for you as a
matter of fact it's an XL my former size
I am now an L oh well done
oh no we should well wear it at the same
time we could both fit into it at the
same time which would be a very
comfortable brother experience yeah
everyone it could be like a creature out
of neverending story like I'll be on one
side you'll be on the other side it's
back to that I claim logo so you got to
be in the blood side alright once you go
black you never go back
that's true that's true I've had many
black men in my life ever since thanks
for starting was enough for the coolest
item number three I now the retention
rates going to go down oh yeah yeah I
see that one spider Fox spider bucks
what up may 2017 genius what's the
spider looks it's spider-man but a fox
[ __ ] yeah
I don't think it's a real thing it's a
one out boxing exclusive not a [ __ ]
okay ready I'm so ready
POW right in the kisser whoo something's
in here basic squeeze it's a box it's a
box with something inside Oh God open it
faster please
[Music]
oh so cute whoa okay I'm going to be the
prettiest guy at the gym I have a photo
of this like I'll take a photo video of
it there's the pink plug-in point
oh this time I got purple Wow we're
going to do this again so pink plugin
point there okay here we are at the JV
cam we have the purple plug-in points
this is very representative of the
marble in DC Universe purple because
they bruise each other damn right this
is your own okay so we have Superman
Iron Man Wonder Woman penny I hope the
food that - well it's it's Batman huh
it's definitely see a it might completes
the photo that's the top part of that
man this is the bottom half of that no
it looks weird
okay oh yeah no the whole thing's very
confusing
okay so it's DC yes yeah oh man
including Marvel's Iron Man oh haha oh
my god I'm going to be like this
actually this is DC and horrible these
headphones are going to get attention at
the gym careful the ladies are going to
be with you asking you where you got
those from wow this is soundproof I
can't hear [ __ ] oh there is enough fat
anymore I wish it was more like him did
you hear that
alright what's next - Chara
okay this is the last thing I'm ready
ready I'm ready
oh my god stripper Iron Man oh your bed
hi good effort an Iron Man
does laser beep rocket the dish
shoulders the wrong song it's no no no
no
Iron Man Iron Man come in with a good
bite I know who I see we're good jokes
go to die anybody else know you can have
a box jellyfish Thanks yeah I was
looking forward to this Olli Wow here's
the cool liars well guys thank you why
not boxers sending that my way there's a
referral link in the description box but
go ahead and buy yourself a one out
boxes well use the referral link it
doesn't benefit me at all that's not a
lot that's what I would use to buy one
yeah and I reap nothing I wish you would
benefit you because you're talking about
their stuff and I know it'd be great
like helped you out in some way for
talking about their awesome items which
you can get only out of the kindness of
my heart don't be deceived that the real
rejects are in the specific link in the
description box
yeah you're just doing a benefit that's
totally you know generous is your line
this a my are helping a big company up
mmm very nice I wish more people would
do that I don't make eight bucks a
purchase all right yeah go ahead you can
subscribe to the real rejects click the
notification bell jab eco is on the jab
eco a channel he's got to javi collate
channels ones American ones
International is American Channel
significantly more popular the Charter
Kurt you Potter online at a charter and
she's a Miko a channel a lot yeah
youtube.com slash guitarra what you have
a channel I do there's so much content
right yeah like you think you got a lot
of videos you should see a charge
Hamilton's one two videos more coming up
I finish working for my Mazda and the
second video is an introduction
yeah welcome to my channel right but
stuff will be for the coming you want to
see me do more things like talk about
random stuff and unbox things for every
state with no Commission whatsoever no
Commission whatsoever every youtuber who
doesn't boxing doesn't get paid no
youtubers work for free mmm-hmm
I've actually don't
something perfect now we got another
video roaming embossing for free well